[تصفيق]
كما تعلمون هذا الأسبوع ،
جاء جو بايدن إلى فيلادلفيا
بنسلفانيا
لإلقاء أكثر خطابات الكراهية والانقسامات شراسة على
الإطلاق من قبل رئيس أمريكي
يشوه 75 مليون مواطن بالإضافة إلى
75 إلى 150 شخصًا آخر.
إذا أردنا أن نكون دقيقين بشأنه
باعتباره تهديدات  للديمقراطية وكأعداء
للدولة ، فأنتم جميعًا أعداء
للدولة ،
إنه عدو الدولة ، تريدون أن
تعرفوا أن عدو الدولة هو هو
والمجموعة التي تتحكم به والتي
تدور حوله ، افعلوا ذلك لذلك جو.
ستفعل هذا جو بشكل صحيح ،
أعتقد أن فيلادلفيا
كانت خيارًا رائعًا لجعل
خطاب الكراهية هذا
في حالة من الغضب ،
كان حديثه عبارة عن كراهية وغضب
بالمناسبة في صباح اليوم التالي ، لقد نسي ما
قاله لقد رأيته
أنهم سألوه عن يا أنا
لم أعتقد أنني قلت ذلك ،
أليس كذلك؟ كيف أحببت الإضاءة الحمراء
خلفه مثل الشيطان